I'm poppy and Heinrich I'm going to be
talking about function repository and
resource functions new inversion globe
I'm Bob San Hinrich and developer here
at Wolfram and for the next hour so I'm
going to be presenting on resource
function and the new function repository
and also briefly talking about other
repositories so it's a brief agenda
first I'm just going to recap hopefully
for most of you what a resource object
is and what we mean by repository in
this context and then we'll briefly go
through the two repositories that we've
already released the data repository in
the neural net repository and then we'll
spend the large chunk of the talk on the
function repository and resource
functions and then real quickly we're
gonna you know I'll demo the formula
repository and then I'll just show a
quick list of things that we're gonna be
working on in the future so hopefully
some of you have used a resource object
already what for either the data
repository or the neural net repository
in the data repository they're sort of
up front so you probably would have
encountered something like this and what
a resource object is is basically it's
just a wrapper around metadata if I open
this guy up you can see that there's a
lot of keys and values displayed in this
summary blob and it's so it's a wrapper
for metadata but it also points at
content and in all cases the content in
these resource objects is something
that's immediately designed to be used
in the Wolfram language so for data
repository the content is data we can
look at the content of this guy real
quick if we want it's a 3d model you
know we consider data to be basically
any static expression in the Wolfram
language for the neural net repository
its neural networks for the function
repository the content is from
but they're all things that you can
access via a resource object and use
immediately and so for once we've sort
of put in a bunch of effort to curate a
lot of good examples of a specific
content type we bundle those up and
publish what we call a repository so
when we make our posit ory we make a
website for it we make it searchable we
break things down into categories and we
you know hook it up into top level
functions for you to use so the first
repository was the data repository I
came out in 2017 we can look really
quickly at the website you only see here
all the resources are broken down into
different categories and the important
thing to notice each one of these things
if we just pick one each one of these
things has its own web page where it has
its name a brief description and goes
straight into examples and all of these
examples are things that you can copy
and use immediately in the Wolfram
language you just click on an example
and you go back and you paste it in and
it works try it in the research into in
a notebook anywhere here's another one I
copied just for an example of a data set
like we saw in the previous page they're
not all data sets the previous page had
a 3d graphic object so it can be a graph
network it can be audio it can be sort
of like I said any static expression we
can treat as data in the data repository
and this isn't just an example I used of
doing some analysis on on that meteorite
landings resource i'mso and this is
straight off the webpage so what
separates our data repository from the
myriad other that you'll find online is
that it's actually useful a lot of times
it's just a place for people who publish
things to stay they've released their
data without the intent of anybody
actually using it so if you can track
down the PDF that has a graph in it it's
not really useful sometimes it's a
spreadsheet sometimes it's it's
something some JSON or some
and useful but none of it none of them
have these examples that you can
immediately compute with and know how to
use so the second repository we released
is the neural net repository if you are
at the tech conference last year you've
probably heard about us so you're saying
come on that was 2017 well that was sort
of ended up being a sneak preview after
the conference we decided there was a
little more content we wanted to get
into a little couple more features we
wanted to get in before we really went
loud in public with it so that ended up
happening in early 2018 so and that we
can again look at look at the website
briefly this one instead of having it
broken into categories on on the
homepage it's all the neural networks
are just listed here probably we're
gonna have to do something about that
soon it's getting the point we're
scrolling is untenable so we might see
something move towards the data
repository design before too long but if
if you've managed to avoid neural net
talks so far in this conference I am
amazed so I'm not gonna I'm not going to
spend too much time on our neural
networks you probably already know that
they're outstanding and one thing
that'll sort of motivate talks later on
here's here's a colorization net that
takes a grayscale image and colorize it
and this is a little utility function
that's on the web page for this net and
a few other nets that sort of help you
take the raw inputs and outputs from the
net and create sort of a function that
even someone as simple as me knows how
to use so let make sure that's print out
the gray one there too so there's color
and gray and then we can see how this
met does it turning it back alright so
it thinks this is sort of blue behind me
instead of red that's interesting so
this is sort of packaging up of the raw
net into easiest functions it's
something that once we had these nets in
the repository we did for you in a lot
of cases like image identify and imagery
style these are all things that have
neural networks under the hood that are
distributed by the neural net repository
using resource objects and you might
used him a hundred times and not ever
realized that they were using resource
objects but that's the empowering
technology
so now the third repository that were
publicly announcing is the function
repository and that's happening right
now so you know Steven talked about in
his keynote on Tuesday and and Rick
mentioned some stuff in his talk
yesterday but now we're spending more
than a couple minutes on it really
getting into some details so let's start
off looking at the website again so
these are the the initial set of
published functions you can see start
like neural net we've just started by
just listing them on the homepage we're
going to sort of see where where you all
want to take us with content before we
before we try to categorize the entire
world of computation so you know each
one like just like before each one of
these has its own page where there's a
name and a description and examples that
you can use right away we've added a
couple more sections here to make this
look just like almost just like the
documentation notebooks that you're
probably all very familiar with so we
have these usage boxes and the details
and options and all this stuff is click
to copy so you can click here and copy
it I'm going to grab one of these
examples if I go back to my notebook I
can put it in it'll work right away I'm
going to do a few more of these just to
make it more fun
let's just play with some numbers I
don't even know how big this monitor is
we'll live dangerously all right here we
go
no hands all right okay so they I mean
this seems like something that's sort of
frivolous and silly maybe it is but yeah
that's good for a function repository
plus there are real applications like we
internally do a lot of like interface
testing so this is something that you
could use to sort of automate moving
Mouse's to precise locations and
clicking to make sure that the notebook
interfaces don't regress something along
those lines so even even something that
sort of fun and silly can be really
useful so it's a brief overview of how
to use one of these functions from the
repository so you do I sell that here so
if I if I take this guy and just
evaluate it what you get back is this
little pill shaped blob and so you can
put this anywhere in your code so if I
do something like you know move up of X
all right I guess I didn't quit after I
practice last I saw that I could do
something like this let's go hold on one
second what was it on the last slide
that guy can't remember things like that
and I think this is negative I think the
top of my screen is so here's this guy
we got move up and we can say move up of
300 there we go alright so you know you
can stick these little resource function
blobs straight in your code anywhere and
they'll work whether you're in cloud or
desktop assuming you know you can access
our cloud if with an internet connection
you don't even need to log in so so that
that's how you can sort of use one of
these things also these like I said
resource objects inherently have
metadata so you can get the properties
of these things you can wrap it in
resource function again and say
something like description and I'll get
that probably a better more useful thing
is you can say example notebook
miss will pop open the same examples
that we saw on the webpage in a nice
notebook that you can evaluate on your
desktop or cloud if you're in cloud
these all the examples just will just
work anywhere and another important
thing to note is that you can go back
and forth arbitrarily between resource
objects and resource functions so
resource object of the resource function
gives this guy which hopefully we're
somewhat familiar with and then you can
you can go back to resource function so
this is useful because resource object
sometimes is a more useful workflow for
looking at the metadata of the resource
whereas resource function is what you'll
you actually used to apply the function
to things so so that's sort of the most
basic use case so sure go ahead we're
gonna get there hang on tight okay all
right so the next thing we're gonna look
at is defining your own resource
function and there are a couple ways to
do this the fastest and easiest way is
using defined resource function so this
is a new symbol in 12 so I'm gonna
define something called put a bird on it
so first I need to get a bird I'll use a
web image search that's that's a cute
little bird but I don't it's a little
bit too big to put on everything so
we'll make it smaller and we'll define
this function see that it works okay so
there's a function and now I'm going to
turn it into a resource function so
here's my blob and I can say put a bird
on it you know everybody likes to do
plot this one works out well because the
bird needs a little hill to perch on so
we'll give it a little hill to perch on
there we go so uh yeah it's just a fun
little thing so you can define a
resource function just like that real
easily
so I before we move on much further I'm
in get into some of these details about
the nuts and bolts of resource functions
so the definitions are included are
imported into the resource function when
you evaluate define resource function so
if I have f that depends on G and I
define a resource function for F I one
thing I should also mention if you
notice in the last example I just used
one argument to find resource function
and the function itself was named the
same thing as the symbol that I use in
this case I'm using two arguments my
symbols elf F and I'm explicitly giving
a name of F but also G so so you know
the definitions for F and G are included
at the time I do define resource
function if I clear G I can grab this
guy and it still works and that you know
so the definitions are maintained as
sort of a snapshot if I redefine G or F
it's still gonna give the same thing
because they're imported at the time and
the way this is done if you're
interested this is you know totally
unnecessary to know for any normal usage
but you guys are all very inquisitive so
it we create a symbol an internal symbol
in this big ugly context that actually
contains the definitions that the
original symbol had so yeah this this
symbol works just like the resource
function it works just like your
original function we'll put this back to
five that makes more sense
all right so that's sort of the way
simplement is all of the dependencies
are moved into a dedicated context and
those definitions are stored in the
resource function which as you will see
later you can then export locally on
disk or deploy to the cloud or any of a
number of things does that does that
answer your question okay
sir you can we'll get we'll get there uh
no this that's a great question
so another another thing to know is that
attributes are supported so I think we
can all agree that addition is a
terrible sin and we all want functions
to avoid it so if I make this never add
function that has this hold first
attribute basically if there's a plus in
there it's gonna throw a warning so the
resource function you know has the
attributes are passed on the resource
function that works just the same so
that's a nice thing to know also these
things like attributes will work right
on the the resource function so you can
just put in there that so here's here's
an ugly way to see the definitions there
are prettier ways one of which have we
probably I don't know if we publish
we've published a resource function that
shows prettier ways to do it so I don't
know if I don't know if it's actually
made it out yet but it's it's in the
queue if it isn't but yeah this is sort
of a if you don't mind looking at ugly
code with big context in it you can see
it that way you can like I think I guess
I already showed this already you can go
to resource object use that to view
properties as well since all I did was
make this with defined resource function
the metadata is not very filled out and
very rich
one other note that getting a bit
technical but might be important to some
of you if you're planning on using this
is that resource functions are really
intended to work with down values
they're expected to take arguments and
give results so if you do a lot of
programming using up values on your
symbols you will run into some issues
when you try to create resource
functions with from for those symbols
with up values for example here here I
made something called which def that has
an up value for plot if that's if plot
is invoked it returns up values if
anything else any other single argument
it gives down values so when I use that
symbol directly
it gives it uses the up value but if I
replace it with a resource function made
from it it doesn't it the plot works on
on this on a string which just can give
an empty plot there are case also cases
where up values are used so here I'm
using this plot instead of plot and I
have a double slot here and it turns out
that just like just like this symbol the
resource function invokes the up value
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
going into all these details but if you
think about the fact that the
definitions are really in this internal
symbol you'll figure out why this
happens in five minutes and if not I'm
happy to explain it to you
after the talk okay so why why do we
want a resource function ever we already
have a function it's a symbol I've been
doing this for 30 years
don't tell me my functions aren't any
good well you probably don't if you just
want to keep doing the same thing you've
been doing for 30 years if all you're
doing is using is defining functions
that you know how to use and you just
want to use them locally and then
there's really not any reason except
that it makes a pretty-looking
pill-shaped blob but the two big reasons
that you will want to do this is it
allows you to add metadata to your
function so all resource objects like
I've said a couple times are contain
metadata that is you know wraps around
the content so it can Evan it can have a
description it can have you know
additional keywords for searching and
most importantly it can have
documentation so sort of you know we've
been documenting our own functions a
long time and it works really well and
we have some of the best documentation
system in the world but we haven't had
success in creating a system that lots
of users have used to create
documentation on their own so this is
sort of our first or maybe not first but
our newest foray into trying to do that
with some success so you know being able
to document your functions
is important for your own use really but
especially if you want to want to share
your function with somebody else and
then the second main benefit is
distribution so once you've added this
resource object and resource system
layer on top of your function you
immediately have the tools to distribute
it either via your cloud account or if
your if if you think it's in the good
for the public interest you can submit
it for publication in our function
repository so those are the main
benefits so how do you create a resource
function with a rich filled out metadata
collection and the way to do that is
with what we call the definition
notebook and there's you can get a
definition notebook in 12 doing create
notebook a function resource but it's
more fun to use a resource function to
create a resource function it's very
meta so we have we've published this
resource function called create resource
notebook that you can use even an 11-3
and so here is the definition notebook I
know at least a couple of you are
familiar with the one of these that we
made for the data repository it has not
been a great success so this is a much
better attempt at it I think so we're
doing a we rethought a lot from that
process so if you'll bear with me we're
going to take the next few minutes and
fill one of these guys out and you know
we have functions like labeled and
framed there's one that we publish in
the function repository already called
circled but we we don't have anything
called wiggled so we're gonna we're
gonna take a few minutes and make a
wiggled and so this so that you put the
name of the function there then you add
a description and this is I think of it
as sort of like a little marketing
tagline so I'm gonna say add I should
have turned off my church and I add
wiggly jiggly
attitude anything and then we're gonna
say then you just go right ahead and
define your definition so this is gonna
take any kind of expression and we're
gonna say with Wiggly equals will use a
dependent function so we're gollum egde
rasterize expert and then let's check
for failures if failure Q wiggly dollar
failed otherwise interpretation
interpretation Wiggly expert all right I
need one more bracket no so I do and
then we need to do this wiggle image I'm
gonna cheat on this I have it it's a
one-liner but there are some options
that I just can't remember for the life
of me with limit equals that guy image
transformation is a fun fun function if
you've never used it and then we'll add
sort of a catch-all failure thing here
alright so now we have our function that
obviously is about to go viral so the
next the next step is to create
documentation so wiggled
I'm putting expert here it was also as
an actual name of the argument that's
just a coincidence it can I could have
used anything let's see displays a
wiggly
version of expert which is interpreted
as expert when used as an input there's
a art to writing these things that I am
a novice at and I think maybe three
people have ever mastered it so if if
you have a function that has multiple
use cases maybe there's a two argument
form you can just hit enter and you know
make another one wiggled
you know a1 a2 and then so just hitting
Enter can make you can make as many of
these use cases as you want wiggled you
know it could take a wiggle function as
a second argument but that's for another
day so now you want to say details and
options
Yeah right right
I agree yeah all right we wanted to do
more like structured searching in the
resource system in general it's
definitely something that's on the near
term to deuce I think I agree yeah yeah
all right so details an option so we
want to say the result is I should say
yeah I know there's an hour long talk
there's probably some other ones
starting do not feel shy if you want to
go to any of the two o'clock talks sorry
oh yeah absolutely
the result is and interpretation object
you can say the wiggle function is 0.02
sine 20 hash there we go
all right so now now we've added some
notes that people need to know examples
so like I was saying with the data
repository and all the other
repositories having examples to fill in
your documentation is invaluable people
love it you got to do it
so caption input output is the way to go
so caption is wiggles text and then we
say wiggled of hi Bob valuated a it's
wiggled let's do another one
wiggle and image
I'd say wiggled resource data
we'll use the data repository to find an
image there we go
funhouse mirror style she was cuter
before but that's okay let's say one
here about how the interpretation thing
works
Whittle data set and I can't type one
out fast enough so we'll grab one from
the documentation page if it wants to
open there we go
wiggled and then we want to say the
result is still interpreted as a data
set all right so we got this guy we want
to show this so we do something like Oh
see there we go all right so this this
is a fine set of examples you could
certainly fill out more and you know
this is sort of I think it's like the
minimal good point to make a resource
function but I'm gonna be more ambitious
I'm going to think about submitting this
for publication so I'm going to fill out
some more metadata contributed by Bob
Sam Heinrich and then keywords which
helps with searching so with a little
jiggle wavy bumpy sine wave you know
come up with anything that you think
somebody might search for that she
returned this related resources would be
if there was another function that was
you know sawtooth version of this you
know that would be a related resource or
something from the data repository you
know if we have like 3d graphics of
ruffles ridges put that in here where
the neural net repository if there's a
you know there's a net that makes things
looks like van Gogh painted it that's
sort of Wiggly so that you could put
that in here I'm not gonna do any of
though links to other things you know
maybe like a mathworld link is a good
thing to do if you're doing something
you know sort of mathy and then test its
it's always good to you have a
verification test so I'm just going to
do a head of wiggled of foo it's sort of
the simplest case and if you have a
published function in our repository
with these tests every time we do any
kind of update whether it's a
mathematical version or a cloud release
or an update to the function repository
itself we'll run this as part of a test
suite if something goes wrong either
we'll fix it if we think it's our fault
or we'll let you know if you're using
some code that's out of date
all right so there we have a completed
definition notebook you can put notes
down here to yourself or to the reviewer
they will not be part of the resource
function or the resource object there's
just something that sits in the notebook
so first thing I'm gonna do is say
deploying this session only well this
does it gives us this little result bar
that has this tiny little guy I'm not
sure how well you can see that but we'll
go back to my presentation so you know
now we can use this in this session
anywhere
range of a hundred it can now we can
wiggle things as much as we want in this
session so we have a resource function
the next thing you're gonna want to do
now that you have this nice function
with metadata and documentation is share
it so the easiest way to do that we go
back to the notebook we say deploy
publicly in the cloud it's going to chug
on that for a minute it's mostly
spending time rat you rasterizing those
examples so that we can make a good web
page and so now we have an example
notebook or I'm sorry a web page that
contains the examples from our example
notebook and key things this and if we
if we grab one of these things and I
placed it back here you'll see that now
the resource function contains a cloud
object so you can send this the URL of
the cloud object to your colleagues or
you know blast it out on Twitter and
this any
I can use this anywhere and they still
see your through documentation and the
function will just work for them for
example my my colleague Rick here he he
made a resource function called burn
peak so I can just use this it gives me
a resource function I'm not even sure I
think this does something oh that's
disappointing
alright well anyway if you want more
control over this thing you can use
cloud deploy instead of the notebook
what what so if you instead of using the
button in the definition notebook you
can use cloud deploy directly so you can
take the resource function let me just
go back here and grab that again if I if
I have that resource function I can come
here and I can say I want this to be in
my cloud resource functions may be
shared may be wiggled right so you can
sort of control your your cloud space
that way and more and also a good thing
you can do you can control permissions
so if I want to send this back for read
Rick I can do and again he goes to read
and that will you know so now instead of
being public for the whole world this
cloud object is only shared with him and
since he he gave me this wonderful bird
with the sunglasses I'm gonna help him
make some things Wiggly yeah if we look
at this it's just like the one we sent
publicly but it's in a in the URL that
we specified with the permissions we
specified so that's sort of a great
workflow for maybe internal tools that
you want to use within your company or
your organization but not published for
the whole world but you maybe you make
something really great and you want to
publish it for the whole world there's a
button for that here we can just say
submit to repository
it'll chug on that and in a few seconds
it should give me a submission ID
and what this is going to do there we go
so now we have a submission ID so this
enters it into a queue for review all
and we'll talk about that submission and
review process in just a couple minutes
in addition to that button we also have
this function resource submit you put
your resource function right in there
and do it programmatically as well how
am i doing on time
plenty of time alright so what should
you submit you know we don't want
somebody you don't want a function
called never ad right but we you know
the things that these are things I think
you should submit things that you have
always thought should be in the Wolfram
language the holes that we've had that
you've forever said why don't they have
a function for this I can write it in 10
minutes so send that to us also anything
that's really focused on your domain
something niche if you have some
computational tool that's you know about
you know only about you know orchids
right computing heat transfer on the
leaf of an orchid sure let's put in
there it's never probably never going to
be something we want top level from
language but it's good for the function
repository there might be 10 other
working people and they'll all like it
are something a little fun you know we
take the Wolfram language very seriously
for good reason and I'm glad we do when
we want to put a function in the Wolfram
language and so long process of you know
you know coming up with a concept right
Kevin design implementing it reviewing
the design reimplemented it it can take
a long time and because of that you know
we we don't put silly trivial things in
there Ralph we don't have the Easter
eggs so but for the resource function
the bar is a lot lower so if you want if
you want something it's not so serious
send it to us and then the rule I've
been using so far is anything I've
written in 10 different projects but
it's gotta it's gotta get submitted
right that means that means it's a good
thing that's missing and that we we need
to and you know what it we
hope that this will become for a lot of
functions sort of a proving ground for
something we might want to put in the
Wolfram language system properly but for
some things like that orchid thing it'll
just forever live in the function
repository all right so that's
submission process
sure go ahead right it's sort of the
same naming convention as Wolfram
language symbols in general so you know
no spaces or special characters just
letters you know it says to start with a
capital letter should be camelcase
that's sort of that's the convention and
you know it we have a when you submit
something he doesn't immediately put out
there so as part of our review we're
sort of going to take on the burden of
controlling namespace so if two people
have something called bird peak it's
going to be up to us to choose which one
is the right bird peak yeah oh if yeah
yeah if there's one in the repository
and one you've created there's the one
you've created will will take precedence
but we have we have a function we can
use delete object on the resource object
and I'll clear it out and then the next
time you're invoking it it'll come from
the repository all right also each
resource object has a UUID in the
metadata so instead of using the name
you can always just use the UUID and
resource object and then use resource
function on that resource object and
it'll think there will be no ambiguity
because new IDs don't collide um right
so submitting oh sorry go ahead alright
so so one there's one final sort of
hurdle before any human is going to look
at the thing you submitted and consider
its merit and that's having access to a
publisher account so this is basically
just a hurdle we have because getting a
wolfram ID is super easy any bot can do
it so this is so if you go here all you
have to you'll fill out this form we
have you know one of our people here
will look at it
if we think you're a bonafide person
that wants to do something nice for the
world and that someone who's just gonna
send a spam and not a bot
we're probably gonna approve your
publisher ID but that's that's that's
sort of one little hurdle and even if
you don't have a publisher ID when you
click that button it'll put it in the
queue and it will it'll send you an
email saying action required go fill out
this form and when once once you've been
approved for a publisher ID then that
what we call provisional submission will
get moved into the actual queue for for
review so so that publisher ID is sort
of one thing to take into account and
then the review process there may be
some back-and-forth typically over email
with our team if we want to make some
tweaks or we want you to resubmit with
some design change we think that it's a
good idea but it's not quite done right
or you know your examples are terrible
you need to fix those up and one other
thing we've consider doing and this
isn't we're not sure we're going to do
this yet we might sort of release things
initially as provisional so what this
will do is it'll make a resource
function and this one is actually when I
created if you remember when we were
looking at the neural net repository
there was that net evaluation function
that's this and so it's doing the exact
same thing as the example of the
beginning so instead of having on the
neural net repository some eight lines
of code that's not particularly pretty
you could just throw a resource function
there but I'm not sure about the name or
the syntax here so we might be sort of
create these and then they're usable by
anyone who knows the name or knows the
URL but they're not really discoverable
and they come with this banner saying
don't get too attached it might it might
go away so that's that and we might even
do some like live twitch design reviews
on these things so that the community
can have input on these it's an idea
we're throwing around I don't don't set
your calendars yet
all right and about the publisher
accounts we have this dollar publisher
ID so it's not like each user has a
published ID if you're part of an
organization and you have a group of six
people that is our Mathematica user so
you can have one publisher ID for the
whole group equivalent or conversely you
yourself can have access to multiple
publisher IDs you can have a personal
one and one for your organization and
invest if that's the case you can use
this dollar publisher ID before you
click that button just set it to
whichever one you want to be associated
with it and that'll work
or you can use resource submit which has
a publisher ID option so if if you have
multiple publisher IDs I don't think
that's an issue for many people yet so
yeah so that's started the function
repository and resource functions and
the submission process your shotty know
the publisher ID is only for submissions
to the public repository the permissions
was for a cloud deployment so that's
something that is just a cloud object in
your account and there's no there's no
home page or discovery mechanism
besides you emailing the URL out to
somebody or you know yeah like promoting
it on your own Twitter or you can
certainly welcome to make your own home
page using using all of our great cloud
tools but yeah so that's the permissions
don't apply to the yes
yeah just like any cloud object it it
literally is a cloud object so it takes
the same all the same options and I was
using cloud to play a resource object
just like you would an API function or a
notebook anything that cloud deploy
takes you can just put a resource
function or a resource object in there
all right uh sure
I meant I'm gonna cut you off we're
gonna get to that later yeah yeah so all
right so anybody else want a question on
functions all right
so formula repository may be sure but
there's a beginning but we're getting to
it at the end I did if we ran out of
time I was gonna skip it
so this is another repository we made
that is there's a public website and
it's out there to use but we just
haven't really found the right
opportunity to promote it or announce it
so it's just sort of been sitting there
for a couple months so if you're
familiar with formula data in the
language this is basically the same
thing but what we've added is a web
interface for searching them and using
them so here we have them broken down
into different categories we look at all
the physics formula that involve one
variable with angular velocity that we
can choose one of these things and
what's great you know like like with all
the repositories there's a name there's
a description if you come down here
there's copyable examples and you can
use red in the Wolfram language anywhere
but there's also this form so this is
just a public web form that anybody can
use so I see ten years you know we're
good at units angular accession one
Radian per second squared
ten Hertz per second would be equivalent
right let's play with that initial
angular velocity 100 rotations per hour
let's just throw some things at it and
see what happens
oh did I give this wrong just hurts
no it should be Hertz per second right
oh it's not angular yeah yeah yeah Hertz
doesn't imply like okay all right well
I'll just do what they told us to do all
right so you can see we have some
formatting issues you know you haven't
announced this so it hasn't really been
thoroughly tested that should have done
the times um yeah yeah this websites
live feel free to use it
feel free to report bugs like this to us
but it hasn't really been through our
testing but it yeah this is another
thing that's enabled that's a repository
enabled by a resource system so I
figured I would take this opportunity to
try to get some people to poke at it so
that that's the formula repository
upcoming work for our team we want to
have an API repository where basically
you can submit api's to run in our cloud
that people can make requests to from
any system so you can you know create a
Wolfram language API that anyone the
Python users can hook up to and they can
do things they never dreamed possible
that then a big thing that people are
excited about is a packet repository so
Bob this is where your question comes in
so that we're sort of thinking as of the
patent repository it's like the upcoming
big brother of the function repository
we know that people are very interested
in this no one more than us but that
function repository has made us as
forced us to make several of the tools
that will enable us to build a good
packet repository so probably this time
next year I'll be telling you guys about
the peclet repository that if you've
seen the notebook archive steven demoed
in his keynote there might have been
another talk that mentioned it it's part
of the Wolfram Foundation and
secretly it's powered by biorepository
even though it doesn't live on the
resources sub domain it's a Wolfram
Foundation thing we've been migrating
some demonstrations content into the
resource system to make it easier to
access it in the Wolfram language so you
can just do like resource data of
demonstrations product you know a
4-cylinder engine or something whatever
they're called and it de manipulate will
just show up it's that's the hardest
part of that is migrating ten years of
content and and each case we're sort of
we have to manually adjust some metadata
and at some point we're gonna do service
connections in the repository and
there'll be a host another thing device
is several there there's a long list of
repositories that Bradley here here can
tell you I don't know do I don't I don't
think so no no all right so before Q&A I
just want to give credit to the the rest
of the team that's helped me with this
they're all sitting in the front row
over here
Bradley Rick Cody and my new they're
also also responsible so feel free to
this bird stuff going on so I haven't
seen it for a while okay okay alright
yeah okay presentation mode all right
all right so yeah so that's nice to talk
and if you have more questions feel free
[Applause]